je voudrais pas que les africains
comprennent que c'est notre coupe du
monde
la gagne
moi je pense que ça représente le
caractère du cameroun parce que quand
vous prenez depuis 1972
les jeux déjà qu'ils ont joué pour les
lions indomptables aop les ovations et
offrira donc ça représente vraiment le
look table salut que
la niaque comme on le dit sans vouloir
faire mal à qui que ce soit mais
vraiment sur le terrain
c'est l'art et la récupération de balle
c'est ça que nous voulons que nos
joueurs d'aujourd'hui ou bien le liban
puisse faire parce que quand vous
récupérer plus de ballons vous avez plus
de chance de le garder et marque des
buts
[Musique]
oui
comment la maison très bonne équipe vous
avez entendu parler des joueurs que maps
et l'épée et péter morici m isaac et
j'en passe on avait une très très bonne
équipe mais bon on n'avait pas encore on
n'avait pas encore de la vie aux joueurs
de gagner des trophées les joueurs
étaient présents car uniquement fusée
comment nous n'étions encore une fois on
l'a
[Musique]
groupe e le groupe était soudé c'est à
lui que nous
nous avons toujours la langue
compétition ou alors de se faire
éliminer avant la compétition nous
sommes décidés de deux les métiers de la
bouche double paul durée les victoires à
l'occupation
beaucoup de pays en afrique lorsque les
joueurs à
jouer à l'étranger arrivés dans le pays
on le faisait on est logés dans les
hôtels et c'est du cdt loi était logé à
ailleurs alors moi quand je venais pas
question que j'aille l'autisme je suis
resté avec les autres joueurs qui loge
au camp militaire où n'importe où je ne
savais que moi ça sa marque est
d'ailleurs l'entraîneur et sa maquette
imcopa turquie en ligue 1 il en est
parce que moi aussi avenant et jallet
jared or bien lequel tous alors pdg de
la cave où je travaillais vous et
ensemble nous allons gagner
[Musique]
je pense que c'était c'était un message
est un message fort il ne veut plus été
très fort encore si ce n'est pas de
courir contre l'angleterre mais nous
avons fait quelque chose que je
n'arrivais pas à faire des pires que les
pays africains n'avaient pas fait et
puis vous savez on a des pays qui ont pu
thion
qui ont ils aidé sas à la meuleuse haï
de l'époque et qui est aujourd'hui la
rdc ils ont encaissé deux fois très ému
pendant toute la compétition et toute
l'afrique était un peu tendu pour cela
un loup on dit il faut
vous remettra une équipe à part il faut
être soudé faut se battre sur le terrain
pour que nous puissions effacés c'était
cet épisode qui plus est c'est la mère
et la fille que au plus loin je crois
que nous avons très bien fait
on
[Musique]
pour un joueur toutes les victoires sont
belles moi je prends des parcs vous
savez mes matchs à mort surtout quand je
reconnais roumanie est ce qu'on la
roumanie
c'était quelque chose d'extraordinaire
nous venons de battre l'argentine c'est
le mal qu'il fallait le gagner pour se
qualifier quand vous voyez les deux de
deux beaux buts que j'ai marqués ça
prouve qu'un sabre que nous donnons de
dupont que je peux aller plus loin
[Musique]
ça va être difficile un pays africain de
gagner une course folle mais peu notre
le coup graphique comme le cloud mort et
amusons nous avec avec acs était calme
pour le monde traite est difficile et le
srpi qu'ils ont l'habitude le pensons
pas que l'on arrive à les y est autant
avec
ses prétendantes à rien un ou deux pays
d'afrique et surtout le lot pour
rivaliser avec eux mais si c'est pas
tout le temps parce que le niveau n'est
pas le même
[Musique]
c'était le grip au deuil tout le
cameroun le cameroun a toujours eu une
bonne élève c'est depuis 10 15 ans que
les choses sont on peut gagner parce que
la fédération comme le football n'a plus
fait le travail qu'il fallait faire elle
est que m quelque part les jeunes
joueurs qui les fait travailler pour
accéder à chez les juniors et espoirs et
l'équipe première je pense que c'est
depuis les années 80 que le football
comme un peu baissé
[Musique]
elle date est respectueux et très
respectueux des syriens sur le terrain
moi je dis lui que l'important ce n'est
pas là le ballon d'or de france football
l'autre
le l'important c'est son pays c'est
mieux représentés sont payés parce que
beaucoup beaucoup ont tendance à oublier
que ils ont priori nation que la scène
nationale a besoin il ya ainsi des
trophées